peu
[Musique]
selon l'avocat de la jeune femme
plusieurs cas de sida avait déjà été
enregistré à la maison d'arrêt de
valenciennes et la promiscuité chez les
23 fans qui sont actuellement détenues
justifierait elson les angoisses de sa
cliente
or la demande de dépistage qu'elle a
présenté il ya un mois a été rejetée
d'abord par les médecins vacataires
chargée de l'établissement puis par le
directeur enfin par le juge
d'instruction saisi par l'avocat
un des motifs invoqués la jeune femme
était négative en 85 tests déjà
effectués à l'intérieur de la prison
qu'elle n'a pas quittée depuis
c'est une réponse qui ne peut pas nous
convenir mais de surprend c'est une
véritable atteinte à la dignité de la
dignité de l'homme et qui n'a pas la
possibilité de connaître exactement son
état de santé au moment où il le
souhaite
je vous rappelle que ma cliente est
incarcéré et qu'elle n'est pas encore
jugé que dans le cadre de cette
incarcération préventive elle doit être
considérée comme présumée innocente et
que partant de là on lui dénie la
possibilité j'allais dire élémentaire de
se rassurer sur son état de santé
encore une fois dans un contexte où
cette maladie gravissime fédéral
alors peut-on contracté le sida en
prison apparemment non si les conditions
fonctionnement normal sont respectées on
trouve quand même à valenciennes de
nombreux toxicomanes à cause de la
proximité de la frontière belge à la
direction des affaires sanitaires et
sociales compétentes dans cette affaire
on précise que s'il n'est pas possible
d'effectuer le dépistage systématique du
sida en prison toute demande quelle
qu'elle soit adressée au médecin
inspecteur de la santé de mieux à une
visite dans l'établissement
c'est lui qui juge alors de la nécessité
d soit dans le cas présent aucune
demande par cette filière n'a été
effectuée
[Musique]